we are really trying to understand this
how is it that you boys think referring
to gay people as in today's world is
acceptable because we're not referring
to gay people you can be gay and not be
AAG yeah a lot of aren't gay I happen to
be gay boys do you think I'm a do
you write a big loud Harley and go up
and down the streets ruining everyone's
nice time no then you're not
a what if a guy is gay and rides a
Harley then he's a gay I mean is this
really this hard I don't know
ridiculous all right look you're driving
in your car okay and you're waiting to
make a left at a traffic signal the
light turns yellow should be your turn
to go but the traffic coming at you just
keeps coming and even when the light
turns red a guy in a BMW runs the red
light so you can't make your left turn
what goes through your
mind right but you're not thinking oh
he's a homosexual you're thinking oh
he's an inconsiderate douchebag like a
Harley
Rider this this is making insanely good
sense to
me